foreign
everyone welcome I'm Jack Van Horn from
the University of Virginia and I'm very
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2020 to 2023 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the U of A Brain
Institute the College of Arts and
Sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences
this year's theme is data science and
the public health consequences of the
covid-19 pandemic where we will enjoy
presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with
understanding the secondary health
effects of the covid-19 pandemic
these include delayed Health checkups
treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering
health effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus
participants selected in our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program
leverage these presentations as vital
material are culminating in-person Grant
project development Workshop to be held
at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I'm delighted to welcome our
speakers senpay from the Department of
Environmental Health Sciences at mailman
School of Public Health at Columbia
University at Columbia
Dr pays an assistant professor studying
the effects of environmental social and
ecological conditions on infectious
diseases it develops mathematical models
and computational tools
excuse me to address surveillance
forecasting and control of both seasonal
and emerging infectious diseases
Dr sen fun fact Dr sen likes traveling
and exploring different cultures and
food
and continuing with our 2022-2023
biomedical data science Innovation lab
theme
today's lecture is entitled impact of
covid-19 pandemic on influenza the
covid-19 pandemic has disrupted
circulation of many respiratory diseases
including
influenza and in this lecture Dr pay
will talk about several studies which
highlight the impact of covid-19
activities in different countries
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube if
you're watching on YouTube thank you for
joining us our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical
excuse me data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged
to submit any questions via the chat
feature in their Zoom sessions where
I'll synthesize these and ask them on
your behalf in the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome
Stan we're super excited to hear about
your presentation
thank you so much for your kind
introduction
um so yeah thank you for having me here
so today I'm going to talk about impact
of covid-19 pandemic on influenza we
will have a discussion of how Copenhagen
pandemic has changed the transmission of
influenza in the last few in the last
three years and also talk about what's
the implication for the flu Transmission
in the next couple of years
so the talk will be um structured within
four different topics the first one I
will broadly talk about personal
interactions and some previous studies
on this topic using data science and the
different um statistical and
mathematical methods and in the second
part I will talk about empirical
evidence of showing how Covenant
um how influenza transmission was
impacted by the covid-19 pandemic in the
last three years and third I will use an
example to show how we can use
mathematical models and the counter
Factor simulation to study to quantify
the impact of covid-19 mpis on influenza
in different regions in the US and
lastly we will discuss and talk about
what's the potential impact on future
influenza outbreaks caused by the
covenanting pandemic right okay let's
first start talking about password
interactions
um so we all got common code every year
so on average each person will be um
will experience
um two to three episodes of um we call
it acute respiratory infections
um which is also common uh common code
we know but we know that every uh behind
every of those illnesses there there's a
pathogen right so um there are a number
of pathogens can cause common code those
include many endemic viruses which I
have a list here those are common seam
viruses can cause common code uh
including influenza virus a virus B
respiratory Sensational virus or RSV
um seasonal coronaviruses there are four
different types rhinoviruses human
metanimal viruses human para influenza
type one two three and adenovirus and
also others so this is a part of the
list of those endemic viruses that can
cause common code but also there's a
novel varices are coming up to cause
severe here we call it pandemic right so
um those are the um
um the most popular one could be the the
H1N1 in in 19
um 1918 right that was like um 100 more
than 100 years ago and most most
recently there's 2009 H1 and one
pandemic
um but there's also other viruses from
um from even in from even we could even
influenza right if H5 and one H7 and
nine those are highly pathogenic even
influenza which can cause severe
diseases but it's rare
um and we also heard about emerging
infection disease about Source in 2003
MERS and also Stars Kobe 2 which is
causing the the ongoing covid-19
pandemic
so among those um different pathogens
people have think about whether there's
interactions between those different
viruses well one of the um most
well-known example is the interaction
between influenza and bacterial
infections so here it's not virus virus
interaction but it's it's a virus and
bacterial infection
um here in this figure we can look at
the number of incidences caused by
influenza uh shown in the shown by the
blue line and also the pneumococcal
pneumonia shown by the red line so you
can see both of them have very strong
seasonality the tends to peak in the
winter times and have a lower number of
incidents in summer times but if you
look look at closer you will find it
whenever there's a peak for flu
there's also a little bump for pneumonia
in incidence right so this is one of the
um example people have noticed a long
time ago they found that usually for
those vulnerable people they get
infected by influenza the mortality
usually it's not caused by by the flu
itself but maybe the subsequent
bacterial infection and people have
studied using mathematic models and and
datas to study those interactions they
found that flu interact the flu
infection actually can increase the
susceptibility to subsequent bacterial
infection this is the one very classical
uh example to show how we can
um you know measure personal
interactions
and when it comes to
um
virus virus interactions particularly
respiratory disease interactions here is
a very interesting study from UK
and they look at the um
they look at the um the prevalence of
pathogens among patients in several
hospitals in glaslow UK from 2005 to
2013 and you can see for some of the
viruses here is influenza virus a and
the rhinovirus they tends to have
opposite phasing here when the flu is
high rhinovirus goes goes low so there's
a correlation is negative and also if
you can look at influenza B and
adenovirus there's also a pretty strong
inverse pattern right when there's one
is low the other is high
but at the same time there's some other
pathogens like RSV and metanemovirus you
can see there's a very strong similar
seasonal patterns but also some Peak at
around similar time and also PIV para
influenza virus 1 and 2. so those are
all you know those data
something will show that probably there
may be some interactions happened
across different viruses right between
those different vertices and then we
when we think about that we we always
want to know what may be the possible
Pathways possible passwords for personal
interactions and here's a there's a very
nice review paper uh by uh
papatovsky and and colleagues uh and
they summarize the potential Pathways at
different levels
um for her personal interaction and
those include a cellular level
interactions uh host level interactions
population level interactions right so I
can briefly go through a thumb like at
the center level there may be
computations for the resources for virus
replication if there's one virus
infected one cells the other virus
replication could be impacted right
there's also maybe cell damage caused by
one virus which can change the the virus
replication of others at the host level
interaction it's mostly
um mediated by immunity or physiological
changes for instance if people get HIV
uh it will you know weaken the immune
system which can lead to further
infections which otherwise would not be
possible because of the immune immune
effect right and also there's
cross-reactive antibodies if a person
got infected by a very similar strain of
virus there could be cross protection
happening so reduce the severity or
maybe the chance of infection for that
and there's also like interference
signaling signaling for physiological
changes you can think about like fever
right fever is people have fever then
you have a higher temperature the
replication of all the maybe uh the
viruses will be slowed down not only the
the pathogen causing the fever
um at the population level this is more
related to behavior changes which can
reduce the contacts and travels across
different locations right it slowed down
the transmission at the at the
population level and also there may be
medication use and vaccination that
could change
um you know the the likelihood of of
getting infected by other viruses
um there are many different methods we
can try to use data to identify personal
interactions
um I would argue that the most important
way to do that is you can do some
testing at the individual level so
probably you can have a monkey panel PCR
attack to see whether this person has
this virus virus right and uh and you
can use those very high resolution
granular data coupled with some
regression models statistical models to
quantify whether there's a significant
interactions between different vertices
and on the right is a study from the UK
I just mentioned a few slides ago
um that the the they use the data
individual level data which is really
hard to collect and very expensive I
guess to quantify the um the
interactions and they found theirs their
evidence of strong negative and positive
interactions between different pathogens
um but this data is not all it's not
always available right so people have to
sometimes have to use serverless data
which measures a Time series of disease
cases or other like maybe presented
positive to do those kind of analysis
and people have used multivariate base
and hierarchical models uh to it is a
statistical model
to this entangle the row you can control
a lot of variables to see whether
there's interactions happening but
there's also other people using a state
space method reconstruction
um to you know try to use a framework of
causal inference to see if there is one
um there's a direct directional
interaction between different pathogens
um and also people can use other terms
of Time series method detecting
causality or correlation or even
dynamical coupling
um between different time theories right
um and and lastly people can use some
mechanistic model you can assume there's
interaction term in your model and to
fit the data feed the models of data to
estimate how large is interaction there
so there are pretty bunch of ways we can
measure interactions but not all of them
are working well given the data quality
and all the limitations we have in those
modeling methods
so yeah so that's basically a brief
overview of what you know what people
have done in terms of quantifying
personal interactions but here we want
to look at what what are the empirical
um data showing you know what happened
for flu during the last three years okay
um the first question is how can covet
covid-19 impact fluid transformation
I I guess most of the important
um way we can think about is
um that Source Kobe 2 and influenza
share very similar transmission routes
um this figure shows the potential
transmission Pathways for Search scope
into and you can see many of them
actually work for flu and uh and because
we we implemented very strong mpis
either governmental or voluntary right
um which has effectively reduced contact
between different persons so the chance
of infection for both flu and sort of
covert 2 has been reduced substantially
and also there's a potential effect of
limited travel travel restrictions right
you don't
have that much travel from one location
to the other which can limit
reintroduction of
um flu virus from one place to the other
there has been some studies to look at
co-infections of flu and and influenza
flu and Source Colby too at the
individual level there's one review
paper they gather a large number of
studies and they found that only about
0.7 percent of people have co-infection
confirmed by you know PCR tests
um it's so it's not very common to have
um co-infection but also there are some
studies using those data to show that
influenza actually is associated with a
reduced rate of sarasco B2 right but
there's multiple different ways you can
explain how this Association happened
right
and okay all right let's look at the
real world data in the US in the last in
2020. so let me explain a little bit
what we are looking at here so we are
looking at the curve of percentage of
visits for influenza like illness it
quantifies what's percentage of people
going to the hospital having symptoms
like influenza
um so it's not like a very specific
metric for influenza because other
viruses can cause similar symptoms it's
a symptom based but it can give you a
broader sense of what happened
um over the year what what general level
of respiratory diseases
and we can see their different curve
from different seasons and usually the
ioi peak around the winter time which
you know we understand right uh and also
there here is a special case which is
2009 H1 and one pandemic season it pigs
in the Euro times very early uh in the
season in the in in in the autumn in the
fourth time and here the um
the red red line here shows the level of
ioi in
in 2020 right so this is
um
so you can see during the during the
covid-19 pandemic actually the activity
of IO is very low surprised by NPI and
maybe other factors so we are seeing
very small number of respiratory
infections during the Covenant during
the first year of the pandemic
and there's also a study from Rachel
Baker and other colleagues as Princeton
to look at
um what what is a positivity rate right
you test a number of samples you can
look at what percentage of those
um
samples have
infected by influenza this is a more
specific Target for influenza because
you have to be confirmed by by lab tests
and you can see on the left we show the
um
the percentage positivity in different
states over time and and the red the the
vertical line here shows the timing for
the npis in the US you can see after
that you see a sharp drop of positivity
rate and those dotted lines showing the
previous Seasons the typical level of
positivity rate and and here's a nice
color plot color map shows you know you
can see after
um the MPI mpis were implemented there's
a sharp reduce of
um positively in all states of the US
and the women look at globally we can
use data collected by The Who flunet to
look at
um
how flu activity changes
um during the covid-19 pandemic
um so on the left we show the
um the positivity rate the positive
cases this is positive cases on the
right we show the num samples tested
both in Northern Hemisphere and and
thousand chemistry because the the
winter the seasonal is different right
so it's so you have to look at
differently and uh you can see before
the covid-19 pandemics it's very clear
seasonal pattern in this in the winter
you have a lot of cases but
here if you look at the number of
cases after covid-19 pandemic
essentially it goes to very low level
right it's not there's some data here
it's very low and I'm showing a zoom in
plot here
um the number drops from I think maybe
the order of like tons of Southern to a
few hundred so like maybe only one
percent of previous level and is it
people may ask is this because of people
are testing less during the kubernetes
pandemic actually it's not because here
you can see the number of tests it's
still very high right it's testing a lot
of people but you don't see any of those
positives
and uh and there's some other studies
looking at covid-19
um look at flu activities in different
countries specifically on the left on
the left you can see this is work uh
from China
um those blue line and the black line
shows that um the positivity rate in the
two seasons prior to the covid-19
pandemic but then uh after npis
implemented in China
um also the positivity drops
significantly it's much lower than
previous season and also you can look at
data from South Korea also has very
strong MPI at the beginning right and
those data those dotted line shows the
previous seasons and the um the the
black line shows the data in 2020 so
there's a very strong suppressional flu
activity in South Korea
okay now we look we have a look at some
population level indicators of um what
happened for flu during the covenanting
pandemic then we can think about how
covid-19 pandemic shift the evolution of
flu activity then we need to look at the
sequence look at the lineages and Sub
lineages of flu viruses
um there are four circulating major
circulating flu sub lineages I'm showing
here this is from a beautiful
realization from work from Hong Kong
team
um so they are taking the sequencing
data from gisaid genset which is a
platform people upload
your sequence data right uh and uh we
are looking at a H3 and 2 ah1 and one
those are two major circulating viral
strands and also B Victoria and B
Yamagata
um different colors means different
different strands you know depending on
how you classify them right uh and uh
and the the width of this band shows the
number of samples within the data
um so you can see clearly after
after the spring of 2020
I mean you are losing a lot of diversity
only most most of them actually
disappeared in the samples you can only
have a very small number of active
circulating lineages happened observed
in this in this big database and and
surprisingly there's a has been no B
Yamagata
um sub lineage
observed after spring of 2020. so you
can see it's actually the NPI was so
strong that it removes a lot of those
circulating you know strands and only
remain some some of the major ones
probably in some locations with a higher
transmission or maybe denser population
can sustain their transmission there
and this can be better
um seen by looking at the phylogenetic
trees for the four different subtype sub
lineages right so um you will see a lot
of diversities of the strengths before
the pandemic and after that you will see
a lot of them they just disappear only
have a very small number and only a
couple of them survived uh entering into
um into
um into 2020 uh after and you can see
he's strikingly you can see the the B
Yamagata is just disappeared there's no
uh something of that
um so this has a pretty strong this I
mean this has also very pretty strong
geographical patterns we can see here
um this is also from the same paper from
Hong Kong's which shows very very
informative how
um how the evolution of influenza has
been changed by the NPI right
um so for each of those sub lineages we
have we have a comparison
for pre-cover 19 data and the
covenanting data this is from April 2020
to July 2021.
um before that you can see there's a lot
of diversity antigenic diversity
different strands circulating around
different areas of work
um like for H3N2 right but after that
you will see
um
you can see the the majority of the
strands they just disappeared and only
had two major strengths circulating one
mostly in Southeast Asia and South South
Asia the other one is in west of Africa
um so
so the transformation has been largely
localized because the connection between
different locations has been strongly
reduced there's no traveling
um across different locations there's
very limited traveling actually so you
you will see there's a very isolated
evolution of that and this pattern also
shows for other sub lineages here is the
figure comparison for H1 and one right
you can see it used to be you know
across many local many countries around
the world but now you can only observe
some major ones in West Africa those are
hot spots transmission and for B
Victoria also you use you can see the
similar patterns for the B and Regatta
you literally didn't see any samples
after the covid-19 pandemic
and there's there's a lot of discussions
on whether there's a real elimination of
B Yamagata stream
um and this is because there are several
reasons we can we can think about why
that could happen the first one is
um you know after the covid-19 pandemic
with those strong mpis
um
flu viruses can only survive in several
hospitals some of the places there's a
small population may not be enough just
to sustain those transmission and also
um the survival of
specific strength is affected by the by
the antigenic diversity
um so according to who as of February
um there there were there were no
confirmed B yeah detection since March
2020 so this is a huge you know
information right and the suppression of
B Yamagata could be because of covid-19
actually coincide with a period of low
incidents and low antigenic diversity
for BM Garden even before the covid-19
pandemic the the incidence of being a
God is very low and also the energetic
diversity is very low so you're very
similar
um
and also um probably is because of
people discussing about this probably is
because of prolonged use of a
well-matched influenza vaccine because
in previous Seasons the matching
um for for the big Yamagata while the
component in in flu vaccine is is very
well because there's there's no a lot of
antigenic diversity so there's still a
active debate on whether there's a lack
of detection or is true Extinction which
has may have some explications
um
um what we want to choose in the in in
in in in the students in our um flu
vaccine right and and yesterday actually
I took a look at the data from
whonet on the top we show the data from
from the end of 2019 and until the most
recent data you can see the they have
different strands color coded here uh
you know
this period mostly in 2020 and early
2021 there's almost nothing reported
very small number of cases but if you
specifically look at B Yamagata
um it's dropped significantly uh in the
spring of 2020 and then there are some
sporadic reporting there but it's not
clear whether those are
you know actual transformation or it
could be some extent even in this season
it's a very small number lower than 10
um 10 samples submitted across the whole
world so it's very interesting to look
at how whether B Yamagata will will get
back or is actually
um eliminated
all right then I think the other topic
we want to cover is to use
we know that there's a lot of reduction
of flu activity but can we quantify the
the reduction
can we get an exact number of how many
infections were not happen because of
Kobe 19. but however doing this actually
is not an easy task
um there are a couple reasons a couple
of challenges for doing this the first
one is there's strong variation in pick
timing and pick intensity across
different seasons as you can see from
the earlier figure I showed the the
curve for different seasons even though
people know that flu typically peak in
the winter time but if the peak timing
can be vary and the pick in terms of the
very different according to different
factors so you just cannot take the
historical average and to look at you
know the difference between the observed
and historical average because the
historical average is not accurate for
what happening in that season specific
season
and second one is the types and subtypes
which are having very different seasonal
phasing uh not very different but you
know there's some difference so we need
to estimate A and B separately
um
and then we can think about there are
many factors uh different uh there are
many many difference in the geographical
locations right for instance there's
some Regional Dynamics differential mpis
implemented uh and also maybe the
initial sustainability could be
different at the beginning for flu right
so we want to estimate those numbers for
each region in the U.S uh and here in
this study we we use the HH region HHS
region region level aoi plus which is a
metric we use we multiply influenza like
illness by Laboratory test positivity
rate for influenza ah1 and B
we we are not considering H3 and 2
because there there were basically no
H3N2 in that season
um so um we will mostly focus on ah1 and
1 and B
so how do we simulate
um transmission of influenza and people
have been using mathematic models we
know a lot about the SAR model during
the last few years right so a similar
idea that we can use those type of
dynamical models to simulate
um the um the influenza like illness
plus signal we have here and this is a
model structure here it's a SARS model
uh it's susceptible infected recovered
and susceptible again
model but the transmission rate here
beta is changing over time we impose
some seasonalities uh using humidity
because we know humidity can change the
transmission rate for influenza in
winter when the low humidity you have a
higher transmission so you can see more
cases in Winter and this is a very
simple model right
um we want to calibrate the model to the
real world data using using mcmc method
to estimate parameter initial conditions
in different locations
okay so before we do anything to the
using the real world data we first want
to see whether this model can actually
capture the transmission and the disease
data right so we did some retrospective
forecasting and feeding uh using
historical data here uh so in those
places you can in those figures uh we
are feeding the data to
um ah1 and B from previous season this
is a national data but we also have
Regional data uh and uh the blue dots
are the reported data actual observation
and the uh the gray area The Gray Line
is the mean prediction a mean fitting
and the green area are the 95 confidence
interval so you can see mostly the the
model can
you know can reproduce the general
um seasonality and an epidemic curve
here
um
and then we apply the data apply the
model to the real world data in 2019 and
2020 season so you can see here I'm
using the um uh the vertical dotted line
to show March 15th that's the week when
there's a strong um I think lockdown
happened in New York City and also in
other locations
um we fit the data until this 10 point
you we only use the data before this
time point to fit the model and we can
project model into the future to see
what if there is what if there were no
npis
um you know how many cases were reported
um right so it's it's basically a
counter Factor simulation showing that
okay we we assume this model can
reasonably represent a full transmission
and we want to see without any
interventions what will happen in the
spring of 2020
and then you can compare those
projections with those actually observed
data point here
um so you can see there's some
difference here right but because of the
NPI happened at the tail of this season
so the absolute number of reduction
actually is not that much right and this
is particularly true for B Because
almost it's already goes very low by the
time of people implementing mpis
um
then we can one of other reduction of
influenza incidents compared to the
predictive values within 10 weeks after
March 15 2020 right it's a long sentence
but I basically you
you take the predicted value you minus
the observed value right that's the
absolute difference between the
predicted and The observed and then you
you can you can divide this number by
the predicted value so you will see the
percentage drop during the 10 weeks
period after lockdown and and we saw
very you know some variations
um in different regions in the US can
see some of them they can be
um reduction by maybe 70 percent but
some of them they can be up to 90
percent
um and for B it's even even larger some
of the some have a low of 30 reduction
probably already the the activity very
low but some of them some locations you
can see there's reduction of up to 90 so
it's a so there's some geographical
distribution Happening Here
and we didn't include Region 2 here
Region 2 is including New York's New
York state New Jersey and also somehow
Virgin Islands so I don't know how the
classmates is very different but the
classes are somehow together in the
region too
um but we didn't include that because we
found there's
um abnormal reporting of influenza like
like earnings in region two so this is
data from the flu view
um the percentage of people percentage
percentage of people going to see
doctors with flu influenza like
illnesses and you can see after the
lockdown here you actually see a lot of
more reporting of influence influenza
like illness in region two mostly driven
by New York area
um I think that's probably driven by the
behavior General people get a panic they
want to go to hospital to see
um if they got coveted or flu or other
respiratory diseases
um and uh and then you can see at the
bottom we show the um the number of
positive specimens uh collected during
this period and you can see there are
actually no increased number of specimen
tested during this period so I I mean
that's why the reason you know when we
qualified those you have to consider
some issues within the data there's a
number reporting there so we eventually
did not include this region in our study
and uh and lastly uh you want to I mean
the the last slides I show we quantify
the number of reduction in terms of
incidents
um but what is reduction of transmission
rate beta in the term right so we can
vary beta uh by some multipliers and you
can find the best feeding data and
compare that with you know to see which
is best fitting and to explain
um the observation of incidents after
lockdown and we found that
um the transmission rate uh has the
transmission rate has dropped
significantly across different locations
and in the US for each one is dropped by
half or B drop by maybe one third so
those are some some math some methods we
can use to quantify
um the impact of um the reduction the
impact of covid-19 on on flu
transformation
all right so
yeah those are all all the data we have
in the past we do some analysis
retrospectively but another big question
is what will happen for influence what
what are those means what does this
thing what what do those means in the
future for
um for flu outbreaks
um and people have done this also right
you can use the model for instance here
in in our paper uh we have projected the
model into the future using the fitted
model giving some predefined scenarios
right for instance here we are assuming
okay how about we maintain the same
level of control for 1.5 years and and
then you lift the control at this point
what you would say in in the next few
years right so we are having we are
trying different levels immunity like
this is means the immunity for influence
that can last for two years this was
three three years and four years
um
um we can try different scenario to see
what is look but generally you will see
is after
um after while two years of no flu
activity
um usually once there's a remove of mpis
you will see a huge Spike after that in
that season uh and that will have some
Ripple effects on seasonality here right
so you have to take some time to reach
back to the
just you know this typical seasonal
pattern and there should be some and
this effect depends a lot on on the the
lens of immunity for influenza and
there's another study
um you know I just mentioned from
Princeton the um they look at the
accumulation of Summer people right
during this time it goes much higher so
usually in the previous season when
there's a new infection there's a lot of
people will bring down and then during
the summer it goes up if you want to
goes down there's a seasonal pattern
here but in the last in the last two
well two years
when there's no infection there's a
buildup of the subtle people so so once
there's a removal of those control
measures you will see a lower Spike here
which is far higher than previous
Seasons but here they are modeling RSV
another respiratory virus which is very
also very important
um pathogen but the basic Sim I mean the
basic message is similar you would
expect some
huge uh spikes uh if you suddenly remove
the um the mpis
and then let's look at what happened now
it's like 2023 you know people
um have dropped all those you know most
of those npis in I guess maybe in in the
last two years so uh so you can look at
what happened in the season of 2022 and
2023 I was last
um last winter we have seen a very large
and early
um
outbreak for influenza as is for ioi
um and uh usually at this time you don't
see that high activity because you need
to go really go into the into the winter
to see the ramp up of influenza
outbreaks but in last season we are
seeing very early onset of flu activity
and also the the peak is pretty high
um as I said this is ioi it's not
specific for influenza but it has some
indications of what happened
and then here there's there was an
article from New York Times they're
talking about the the tripod damage
happened in the winter of 2022 they look
at covid-19 RSV and flu activity and
here they are using hospitalization data
so which is more specific it's
definitely a slow flute because it has
to be confirmed for flu
um and you can see uh covid-19 actually
is lower than previous season because
you know um the
it's Omicron and uh and and uh and
there's a very low lower severity so
there's a smaller number of people going
to the hospital and RSV goes much higher
is you know those lines are the previous
historical data it surpassed I think
it's the highest level in the last 10
years probably is is and most of the
hospitalizations are actually for young
children who have never experienced RSV
before uh and for influenza it's much
higher right it's a kind of like it
surpassed the hospitalization caused by
Hoven 19.
um so we do see there's a large rebound
so the model kind of tell us the the
Quant the quality result that there will
be some severe outbreaks happening
um after NPI were implemented but what
will happen this year or next year
um is still not very clear I guess
um
another big topic here is a disruption
on virus Evolution right so we can see
there's a huge reduction in
antigenogenic diversity uh and which
brings in a lot of uncertainty in how
the flu virus will evolve in in the next
few years in in the future the first we
can see you know the answering comes
from the isolated geographical
distribution and those may lead to
Independent Evolution right so there may
be some you know um
that's my location specific students
happened uh appear and then there's
because of different prior infection
history there may be a diverse
population immunological landscape maybe
in different in U.S in China in
different countries they have very
different they will impose different
evolutionary pressure on the on the
evolution of viruses and uh and then you
can think about there's a huge
difference in vaccination for flu so
that's another level of
um uncertainty you don't know what are
the pressure of um for for evolution
impulse by vaccination right and this
has a very you know significant impact
for so for for the vaccination vaccine
viral selection here because if you you
found
usually now we are using very similar
um formula for for the whole for the
whole world but if you found that okay
maybe this area has a very specific
viruses strength for this location how
you can you know
um desire more effective formula for the
vaccine you have to consider those right
if there's a co-circulation of
antigenically distinct lineages it has a
much imposed Challenge on how you select
the formula the virus in in the vaccine
and the other thing
um the other topic I will briefly touch
on is
um because of the there's a lack of uh
flu outbreaks in in 2020 2001
um it may have some implications for our
children because they don't have initial
exposure to influenza at their early age
um there's concept that they call it
immunological imprint imprinting or
original antigenic scene
now this figure shows some of the ideas
uh I'm not expert on this but I I can
generally talk about what the general
idea here right so the x-axis shows age
of the person and the waxes shows the
severeness of disease after infection by
influenza right at a young age if you if
the person got impulse 2 H1N1 and there
will be immune response to developed to
H1N1 right the second time if this
person imposed to H1N1 the similar to be
much lower because there's already some
memory B cell T cells to reduce the
severity of the disease right and later
if there's a slightly different you know
this exposure to h5n2 right this is very
there's one similar
approaching uh there
um so there could be uh might be
cross-protection because of similarity
but if there's a primary infection with
H3N2 which is totally different virus
then
you know uh this person will be primed
to the first exposed virus for the rest
of the life but as a cost of maybe have
a bad
um immunity response to another strand
of influenza so you would have seen a
very severe disease probably after
infecting by another strength
um so um
so yeah that's why you know a lot of
people they they think about what
immunity landscape across different look
across different locations they will see
the they would look at the burst cohort
when those people when the people were
young what kind of Errors they were
exposed to right so this is figure from
a review paper uh so uh this uh this
shows a time from
late
19th century to 2018 and and on top
shows the major circulating uh strands
of influenza right and you can see
different people when they were born
they experienced different viruses and
they may have a a better immune response
later in their life to the first strand
they were exposed but if there's some
other new viruses uh whereas students uh
infected them they may have a bad
response there
and that's why there's some their study
looking at um this effect you see that
maybe the middle aged individuals may be
in the Perpetual state of H3 and to
influenza virus sustainability because
the you know those people were born
around this age they were exposed to H3
and two at that time but now I think the
Contemporary H3N2 is a little bit
different from that so they can respond
pretty well to that stream but if
there's a new for the Contemporary it's
written too they may not they have a
like
um lower
um worse immunological response so yeah
I think that's probably uh I will stop
here and we can I think there's a lot of
unknowns in the future about what
happened what will happen in terms of
flu uh outbreaks I'm just listing some
of the literature and some of the papers
talk about this topic and I hope people
here they can you know get interest in
this topic and try to use data and
modeling and different method to study
this and try to see whether we can help
people to reduce the uh the burden of
influenza in them in the future
all right I just recap what I talk about
first and we talk about the passive
interactions some of the method used in
the previous studies and we look at the
empirical evidence of covid-19 pandemic
during the last three years and we use
the model study to Showcase how we can
quantify
um impact of mpis on covid-19 in the US
across different locations and lastly we
talk about several factors we still
don't know the impact on future
influenza outbreaks so I think I'll just
stop here and take some questions thank
you so much and thank you very very much
I was really intrigued there when you
were kind of touching on some of the
kind of the the genetic influences that
may be affecting the viruses making them
more susceptible or making people more
susceptible to them and I noticed in in
several of the studies that you were
talking about you were talking about
um kind of correlations between viral
outbreaks or viral exposures where there
was kind of a temporal you know as one p
heat so did another one or rather one
peaked and another one went down because
people weren't as exposed I was kind of
curious whether or not there is over a
long time as these viruses kind of are
in the population with those things
happening are there any Trends towards
like co-evolution of viruses that um
kind of make either of them stronger is
do they reach any sort of an equilibrium
where they just kind of are constants in
the population at particular levels or
are there any opportunities for viruses
and the culture of the people that they
infect to co-evolve as well does that
make sense yeah I think um I think that
makes sense but I'm I haven't seen a lot
of studies on that topic I mean because
usually there are a lot of factors
shaping the um the evolution and you
know and also the transmission at the
population level right I think the key
Point here is we are lacking of those
high resolution data to answer those
questions if someone can provide maybe
individual level data uh you know
longitudinal so you can better
understand what's going on there I think
definitely can use a mathematical model
to you know to look at whether There
Will Be steady state or whether there be
some pattern there but it's it's very
important to use those detailed data to
to answer those questions right yeah I I
agree and you know one of the things I
always kind of puzzling on while you
were giving your presentation is you had
a couple of maps that are showing the
you know the maps of the United States
showing the uh outbreak concentrate
operations for these various viruses I
was kind of wondering like when we were
having the covid-19 pandemic the Johns
Hopkins people got very famous for
having their coveted 19 map and whatnot
and it occurred to me that you know we
have maps on our phones right and we get
a weather we've got I've got a weather
app I've got Google Maps I've got you
know several different mapping things
that why don't we have like a virus map
that's really anywhere you are in the
world much like Google Earth or Google
Maps you'd be able to go and see what
the kind of what the weather report is
the viral weather report for your
particular area anyway while you were
talking I went and looked it up I found
this one called
um flu star which is a uh an app that
you can get for your phone
um but it's it it's it's kind of still
kind of low res but you can also Imagine
That
the viral transmissions and its
locations and concentrations are very
much like the weather and as we move
around we're moving around in the space
that the virus moves around into much
like you know we can expect tornadoes in
Oklahoma and we could expect a hail
storm somewhere else that uh these would
be different forms of viral weather if
you will and I'm curious if you think
that there might be something like that
for the in the entrepreneurial minded
maybe they could pursue that yeah I
think that's a the question relevant to
disease surveillance right so currently
the sermon has mostly come from
Healthcare Systems you go to hospital
you get tested they report to the CDC or
on that I mean so this this makes the
whole process very slow I think
reporting for fluids have a lack of two
weeks you don't you don't get the
real-time data yeah so the other option
is citizen science I think there are
some apps called Blue near me so you can
report symptoms or any people you know
infected by some viruses right so you
can report those to there so you will
see
um you know what what the general
prevalence across different locations
but that has a have it yet because you
don't have the Laboratory test right you
don't know what virus it is you can only
know this person has a code it could be
could be clove it could be a flu could
be other things
um so yeah and also I mean that's really
popular to do some have some like
um mobile devices people can try track
you know you have those fancy Apple I I
watch right if you can use those devices
to collect data uh that would be
fantastic but I think the key Point here
is whether do you want to know the
resolution of which virus causing um the
illness if you only only you want to
report illness I think it's possible to
do as long as a lot of people want to do
it
um yeah yeah and you know it's funny I
was thinking as you were just talking
about uh the one where you can report
you know people who may have the flu
near you I could see the downside of
that is that you it'd be like swatting
your neighbor right if you didn't like
them you could like oh that person has
the flu and you could report them and be
mean to them
um but on the other hand I was thinking
that another way that could you know one
could enact something like this would be
to put monitors in say
um monitoring sewer systems for example
um where you could actually detect the
you know the presence of the virus or
which virus it is which was present and
you know most places with a sewer system
would be able to if we had a device that
you could install and it would then
report uh the presence or absence of
various viruses and whatnot that would
at least give us a hint of what's out
there and where is it and in what
concentration and what to watch out for
and could be done in real time without
having to ask people yeah yeah and he's
faster I mean with water services is
very important right now I think
starting from Kobe and people doing a
lot of those and actually there was a
paper published I I was thinking to put
it here uh the the look at the waste of
water data they sequence they look at a
bunch of respiratory diseases in the
data and they found the some of the
common respiratory devices were the RV
RNA copies are lower during the
kubernetes pandemic it was just showing
that this could be a possible way you
can detect uh it's passive you don't
need to get concerned uh you know it's
earlier than
symptoms right you you don't you don't
have to wait until there's there's a
symptom and uh there's a lot of
advantages there but also there are some
challenges for that because you have to
link I mean if you only need to to know
whether there is or not it's easy to do
right if you find it there isn't yes but
if you know the quality you know how
what does this number mean at the
population level uh there has yeah it is
a little bit challenging to do that
because you know all the factors coming
into that yeah yeah and I'm thinking
that the the modeling becomes so much
more than just looking at a time course
right you're also looking at the change
in space of the con where's the
concentration Peak at that particular
moment it's going to move right in which
case it probably has to be with
something like you're solving a second
order partial differential equation or
series of them uh in order to model the
the patterns of the interactions between
the viruses as well you know in space as
well as time and that becomes very
computationally challenging how then
you're absolutely right if there's
people in the loop who have to give
consent or have to be monitored you know
by the time they're reporting it you've
missed a lot of time it would need to be
something that one would have at you
know you'd have in in Wastewater
locations you'd have Samplers that would
report in real time and much like a
weather station on the top of a mountain
someplace you know scattered around the
country one could then interpolate
between them and use them as fixed
points for you know a partial
differential equation modeling yeah yeah
of course it sounds easy when I say it
but I'm sure it's a lot harder than that
um what sort of things what sort of
skill sets do you see data scientists
needing to be able to help develop these
models and make them something that
could be actionable like this
well there are a couple things if you um
if you want to focus more on the you
know the interaction part I think data
science should be able to understand
um you know some of the typical methods
you use to statistical methods to
disentangle interactions between time
theories those are the the techniques I
think is important to know but also I
think it's important to know to have
some biological background about how
those pathogens interact whether what
are the potential Pathways to do that
and if you want to do something
operational you want to you know push
something uh to real to use in real
world then that's a big question because
you have to understand all the
limitations in implementing those things
like what the data limitation there will
be reporting delay there will be missing
data there will be uh you know we
revising
um you know it's a lot of uncertainty
coming into this and also whether how
you can try to convince people to use it
uh especially how do you work with maybe
Public Health agencies um those are
something pretty important but I think I
think
this
is a kind of interdisciplinary it really
depends on which which perspective you
want to focus on
um but I do think it's important to know
both the data and and the biology and
the uh
um you know of the question I think
that's super important because the
accuracy of your model you may be able
to get some numerical accuracy but
there's also the the uh kind of
construct reliability of the measurement
right is it actually reflective of
underlying biology or is it some you
know Epi phenomenon and you're just
really good at detecting it
yes yes exactly yeah
any parting words uh about uh you know
what what's coming next for this kind of
modeling of flu or covid or other
viruses that we have yet to be exposed
to
um oh this is a pretty big topic right
so a lot of people working on this
actively working on this and it involves
a lot of uh fantastic research questions
I think um I think a lot of people
talking about involving human behavior
into into disease transformation right
so how do you because a lot of those
interactions I described was immediated
by human behavior you reduce the reduced
contact then
um then you will reduce the transmission
multiple pathogens not just the flu or
covet I think that's something you know
if you can get a better measurement of
how people interact how people sleep
together and uh without
violating some privacy issues that will
be very very helpful and I do think
there are some data starting to you know
to to to do that uh and uh for for other
questions because I'm not working on
like real biological questions uh and uh
you know those immunological questions
um I probably should not like talk about
those topics but I think mostly in our
research in my research
um in terms of data science I think
measurement of
human behavior is is very important and
how you how you use that data to inform
disease transformation and evolution
that's very important topic right now
that's fantastic well sen thank you so
much for sharing your work with us in in
these ideas about uh you know viral
transmission not just covid but those
other viruses those pesky viruses which
are out there that uh you know we're
sure to uh experience once again here uh
once uh this summer is over and flu
season comes up again but some thank you
so much for sharing this thank you so
much for giving us uh some insight into
uh how best to model this and uh your
work is fantastic
um everyone have a wonderful wonderful
weekend and I encourage you to uh tune
in next week when we have our final
biomedical data science uh seminar
series and uh we'll uh see you then have
a wonderful weekend thank you again Sen